foreign
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 188 I am told
no 187 187 yes well I was told it was
187 but I thought it was 188 that's how
I got confused
um you will all note that we are outside
today we will explain why we are outside
very shortly let us get through the uh
the business of the beginning of the
podcast I am Dr Brett Weinstein you are
Dr Heather Hein and uh we are
um broadcasting today on Rumble if you
want to join the watch party you will
find it on locals please join us on
locals uh we really appreciate it it
helps us out a lot and there on locals
you will find a lot of great stuff
including excuse me
um the watch parties during the live
streams uh we are releasing all of the
guest episodes that hosts have in
conversations with an amazing array of
people one day early on our locals
channel before they're released publicly
to the rest of the world and we are also
beginning this month doing our private q
and A's we've been doing at my patreon
since
um since gosh summer early summer of
2020 we're moving that to locals as well
so lots of reasons to join us at locals
please do that we uh we appreciate it
helps us out a lot also please consider
subscribing to the channel on Rumble
that costs not a bit but it does help us
out as well I'll say one other thing I
did a uh
ask me anything experiment on locals
went very well with one exception they
were building in a new video feature
that we tried out it didn't work so well
apparently The Kinks are being ironed
out of that but otherwise the Q a was
tremendous amount of fun that just
sounds so wrong what King's being ironed
The Kinks being yes that is all right
now you wouldn't tend to iron them out
you'd probably go for a little talk
therapy or something actually really
depends on what your goal is with the
Kinks yes I guess so yeah I guess uh so
187 not Prime
um of course not uh the factors are
prime though 11 and 17 which is kind of
cool and isn't there a name for a
non-prime whose factors are are prime
yes
excellent I'm relieved to hear that
I don't read for what it is I'm sure we
will be told
um all right we're not doing a q a this
week we're going to talk about lots of
stuff like why are we outside what is
the Cartesian crisis that's going on uh
what does Philip Pullman have to say
about storytelling and what is going on
with mammals dispersing alcoholic fruit
anyway
yeah yeah so that's some of it uh we're
gonna talk a bit more about other ways
that you can find us and and find out
what we're doing and supporters and
stuff at the end of the episode which
apparently is behind us
right I don't know
um but first we do have our sponsors for
whom we are very grateful always uh we
have three uh sponsors for you this week
please consider if any of these products
sound um like they would be relevant to
you or appealing to you do try them out
uh they are um they are all vetted uh by
us or in the case of our first sponsor
this week by someone whom we trust if
the per if the sponsor happens to make a
product that is not relevant to us so
this week it's MD hearing soul and Seed
three terrific companies
our first sponsor this week is MD
hearing before we talk about their
product however consider the economy how
much does it cost to fill your Gap your
gas with car these days it's going to be
like that today
um if you're trying to fill your gas
with car you've got bigger problems
um how much does it cost to fill your
car with gas these days a lot how about
filling your grocery cart with food also
a lot have you tried to get a mortgage
lately at interest rates that are
through the roof if you decide to stay
where you are instead and do it yourself
wow I cannot read today materials like
Lumber and Hardware are as affordable as
they once were either everything has
gotten expensive and fast and yet in the
middle of this MD hearing has cut their
price in half they make high quality
simple and effective hearing aids
helping bring audio Clarity and capacity
to people who might not otherwise be
able to afford it about 95 percent of
the people who need a hearing aid only
require a few settings so MD hearing
simplified their product and they cut
out the price hiking middleman to save
you and them money
MD hearing has reduced the price of
their Neo rechargeable digital hearing
aid which has a battery life of over 30
hours and is so small that no one but
you will know it's there to only 149.99
each when you buy a pair that's 300 for
a pair of hearing aids 90 less than
Clinic hearing aids
here's a testimonial from our friend who
has substantial hearing loss and who
relies on hearing aids we asked her to
try this product and this is what she
said
I tested the Neo the new in the ear
canal hearing aids offered by MD hearing
I was a bit skeptical since I've never
liked in the ear canal models of
preferring the stability of over-the-ear
sets they were surprisingly comfortable
and stable staying put without coming
loose even when I wore them to exercise
I tried the Neo in several situations
from Discord voice chat to an in-person
conversation in a room with a white
noise generator and they passed every
test it is true that they don't have the
individual audiogram programming and
smartphone integration of my usual
hearing aids but they have everything
else for less than five percent of the
price they provide an absolute
absolutely stunning level of quality for
pennies on the dollar that's the
testimonial of our friend
who has significant hearing loss MD
hearing has sold over 1 million hearing
aids in the offer a 45-day risk-free
trial with 100 money back guarantee so
you can buy with confidence
so if you want MD hearing smallest
hearing aid yet go to mdhearingaid.com
and use promo code Darkhorse to get
their new buy one get one deal they are
149.99 each when you buy a pair plus
Dark Horse listeners receive a free
extra charging case a hundred dollar
value
head to mdhearingaid.com and use our
promo code Darkhorse and get their new
buy one get one 149.99 each offer when
you buy a pair
all right now I'm going to try out this
reading thing you're so fond of see how
I do our second spot what I've got this
you got this wow your confidence is uh
lovely if misplaced
our second sponsor this week is Seoul
sole footbeds are the original custom
moldable insoles providing affordable
pain relief since 2001. sole footbeds
include a signature supportive Arch
which is clinically proven to reduce Arc
strain in your feet and these foot beds
are great for any Arch height if you
have low arches or flat feet you simply
heat mold them in your oven to at home
to ensure comfortable
I'm sorry
your feet
no no
that's my bad yeah okay these are
amazing these lipids are amazing and you
do you hold the footbeds not your feet
do not put your feet in the oven no okay
all right we're back
in your oven at home
see now you can't unhear it nope nope
what have you done I know I'm sorry
yeah these soft footbeds truly are
fantastic you fit them in well if you've
got really stupid shoes they probably
won't fit in your really stupid shoes
but you could fit them in any any shoe
that actually has room for your feet and
they're amazing they really are good and
I wouldn't heat mold your existing shoes
it wouldn't eat Mulder
just trying to support you man
let's see
all right
anecdotally
did you do it did you do it to your feet
is that what the antidote oh oh entirely
different anecdote oh yeah so that's
yeah anecdotally I will say that sole
footbeds have been a game changer for me
Heather was going to read this ad when
you we're going to get to the reason so
this is Heather's voice Heather says
anecdotally I will say that Soul
footbeds have been a game changer for me
I was born with weird feet weird enough
that I had reconstructive surgery on
both of them when I was 13 which put me
in a wheelchair for months and truly
ugly orthopedic shoes for a year that
surgery was wildly successful and I was
playing Varsity Sports within a couple
of years of having it but it's been a
while since I was 13 and my arches are
beginning to flatten and my feet hurt a
lot more than they used to wearing shoes
with sole footbeds in them is helping
tremendously I have soul foot beds in my
extra tough boots and my hiking boots
and even in a pair of shoes that you
might go to a nice restaurant in
they have multiple styles for different
kinds of activity if you have any foot
issues at all you should seriously try
these footbeds so footbeds are easily
customized while using your oven
yep
no I don't like if your feet were fully
customizable using an oven I could have
probably avoided that whole surgery
thing back in the 80s your feet are
customizable but it takes a very long
time that's one of the lessons of
morphological Evolution yeah but Soul
gets you there faster exactly yeah it
compensates for the hyper novelty of the
surfaces you're walking on boom and the
short time it takes Revolution to work
sometimes yes sometimes which is faster
than you'd think but not fast when I'm
talking about osteology it takes a while
when you're talking about going to
dinner it's just not fast enough okay
Soul foot beds also reduce pain from
plantar fasciitis and shin splints both
of which are really unpleasant
they promote a neutral alignment and
good posture and are particularly
effective at preventing fatigue when
standing walking or walking for long
hours on hard surfaces two-thirds the
people who try Soul footbeds come back
for a second pair and many have trusted
soul to keep their feet energized and
pain-free for more than 20 years if
you've ever wondered whether Orthotics
could add to your comfort or athletic
performance this is your chance to find
out what 17 million satisfied sole
customers already know
as a dark horse listener you can get 50
off sole footbed simply go to
yoursoul.com Darkhorse that's
y-o-u-r-s-o-l-e.com slash Darkhorse or
enter the code Darkhorse at checkout to
get 50 off any full price pair of
footbeds that's yoursoul.com Darkhorse
or enter the code darkhorset checkout
save 50 on soul footbeds today and say
goodbye to sore feet all right that was
a struggle but we did somehow succeed in
getting through it
to our
which brings us to our final sponsor
this week which is seed a probiotic that
really works if you've tried probiotics
before and got nothing out of it try
seed it's designed differently from
other probiotics it's designed better it
actually works your gut and your immune
system work together coordinating your
body's response to the world both around
and within you seed helps improve the
health of your gut microbiome which
means that it supports you becoming
healthier overall our resident gulp Mike
Galt go ahead microbes
see reading is reading may be fun
reading is fun but it's very difficult I
believe the first part of that I am just
simply repeating what I have heard from
experts
they used to say this there were public
service announcements on television riff
reading is fun riff yes they actually
adults they actually pay attention to
the public service advertisements on
television you know why
I was reading
well right they were trying to they were
it was a it was a precursor they were
lying to the children who weren't
reading to get them to read and of
course the children who weren't reading
might not have found it fun on the
children who were reading didn't need
the didn't need anyone to tell them that
was a perfectly worthless slogan but
okay you're um our resident got microbes
directly impact the development and
function of the immune system even
before we're born microbes and form your
immune system teaching our body how to
distinguish between benign substances
and pathogenic antigens that is
substances that our body doesn't
recognize as its own
you can support your gut immune access
the Axis of Awesome in a variety of ways
including by prioritizing sleep new
research suggests that the gut
microbiome has its own circadian clock
and that changes to your normal rhythms
can disrupt your microbes and the
important functions they perform
prioritizing regular sleep can thus help
keep your gut immune access healthy you
can also support your gut immune axis by
taking seeds ds01 daily synbiotic seed
is a plant-based Prebiotic and probiotic
with 24 strains that have been
clinically or scientifically studied for
their benefits 16 of those 21st strains
are specifically geared towards
digestive health and four of the 24
probiotics strains are known to promote
healthy skin your skin like your gut has
its own microbiome seed supports both
gut and skin health
seed is free from 14 major classes of
allergens including but not limited to
sugar animal products soy gluten peanut
glyphosate Dairy shellfish and corn and
seed is basically double hold with its
capsule in capsule design it is
engineered to maintain viability excuse
me viability through your digestive
tract until it reaches your colon where
you want it and the same design makes it
resistant to oxygen moisture and heat
meaning that no Refrigeration is
necessary seeds daily symbiotic supports
gut skin gut skin and heart health and
micronutrient synthesis we have heard
from several people who have used seed
and Report improvements to their
digestive function in 24 to 48 hours
so start a new healthy habit today visit
seed.com darkforce and use the code
darkforce to receive to redeem 25 off
your first month of seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic that's seed.com Darkhorse use
the code darkforce at checkout
all right
you know let's put it this way it's not
the first B minus I've ever gotten oh
yeah okay well I was thinking while you
were reading too about one of the other
advantages of sleep for those of you who
didn't respond to that it was a riff
yeah the rift PSA the reading is fun PSA
is that um while you're asleep uh you
don't have to read
right although if you are dyslexic you
may find yourself having nightmares
about reading I have a call of more than
a few of those God lord yeah I know I
know well it's traumatic especially when
people ask you to do it uh publicly like
was done in school in order to find the
dyslexics and shame them and shame them
yes exactly it does seem to have been
what the purpose was it felt very much
like the purpose yeah I say say I having
been successful at public reading but uh
but I never particularly understood the
value of it especially for those who
clearly were traumatized by it right and
yeah I wasn't the only one there was
there was a couple of lesson every year
you know and and we saw this later when
we were professors um right that um
presumably you never asked people to do
that but um a nor did I
but I had
um nor was it ever my idea too but I
sometimes had teaching Partners who
really wanted us to try doing this and
um the fact that I would let anyone who
wanted to opt out of such things uh
actually made one of my students
um cry later he was so he was so
grateful it had just driven his
I think this is a stupid way to say it
but it's driven his blood pressure
through the roof yeah he'd just gotten
so so anxious yeah it's it's uh yeah
it's a common a common form of trauma
for children which some carry into
adulthood yeah anyway all right here we
are here we are outside why are we
outside all right here's why we are
outside
Heather has that's you Dr Hein uh what's
up also doctor same person
um has come down with a respiratory
ailment that we strongly suspect is at
least what is being called the current
variant of covid well done yes thank you
um
and let's just update people on where we
are with covet I would you tell me if
this doesn't match your your sense of
things but our sense is covet is very
definitely not a highly deadly disease
and people were spooked into all sorts
of dumb Behavior with the false
impression and in fact the cultivation
of the impression that it was deadly
including by treating people in ways
that made them more likely to die and
then counting those deaths is Coveted
deaths rather than aatrogenic deaths
right
but that said
covet is not enough from our perspective
we've had it we've had it a couple of
times I don't know how many times
because the tests are unreliable but
we've each had it a couple times at
least and the
um negative effects are both substantial
during the disease and I don't know if
you can hear that you probably hear that
one airplane going over
um the effects are substantial during
the disease and everything that I know
from my work on telomeres tells me that
the damage is not just occurring and
then over when you get better not only
are there hold over effects from covid
but there is also the long-term
degradation of your capacity to repair
whatever tissues are under attack
yeah so when you say not as deadly a
disease by a lot as we were led to
believe
you are
um also implying but not it's not in
that statement something that you said
very clearly
um somewhat early in our live streams
which is that just because a thing
doesn't kill you doesn't mean that it
doesn't bring death closer right and in
fact almost every disease even
presumably something like a cold does
this so trivially that it's it's
negligible in its impact but the point
and you know if you have a bunch of
damaging diseases and then you die
because you don't look both ways and you
get hit by a bus obviously it didn't
hasten your death but on average you die
from the failure of whatever organ is
essential and collapses first or you die
of a cancer that's basically the two
general Ways to Die naturally yeah and
um in the case that you die from organ
failure each organ has a capacity to
repair damage and do maintenance and
that capacity is finite and anything
that does damage reduces it borrows from
that account and so uh you know if you
do a lot of damage to let's say you do a
lot of damage to your kidneys early in
life and then you wise up and you stop
doing damage you know you can compensate
a bit you can't buy back anything you
lost but what you can do is you can
reduce the rate of damage to below
average and you can sort of catch up but
all of that you can do that better in
tissues that actually have some repair
capacity and not in for instance the
heart as we have talked about a lot
right even though your behavior should
be the same you can't recover that
capacity uh by uh well I guess you could
reduce the rate of damage of your heart
by being super Vigilant of new damage to
your heart
um but yeah the the heart doesn't repair
in a classical sense it scars over which
is still a much better than having an
open open wound in your heart which is a
lethal vulnerability but anyway this is
a bit of a digression we treat covid
seriously even though
we don't fear that we're not going to
get through a case of covid we just
don't want to face an hour demise or
decrepitude or anything like that by
allowing extra damage so anyway when one
or the other of us has this and you know
we do this for other uh ailments too we
might not do it for a cold
but for any significant uh disease we
tend to isolate and in this case
um we needed to do a live stream and as
there was I want people to think back to
early in our live streams we spent a lot
of time pointing out that the advice the
directives that we were being given the
policy changes that we were witnessing
made no sense the bulldozing of sand
into skate parks right these stopping
people from running on beaches and from
surfing the closing of parks this was
some of the earliest
most obviously completely wrong-headed
coveted policy that was frankly part of
what opened the door and opened many
people's eyes to
well if they're that wrong about those
things
what else are they wrong about yeah and
let's just put it to you this way wrong
isn't
pointlessly wrong
the fact is
to the extent that there was some
disease that we were trying to not catch
go outside was like killer advice go
outside right oh your life is being
disrupted you're facing psychological
torment go meet your friends outside too
cold and rainy figure out how to do it
right so
um in any case
we are outside today because although
you are you haven't had it very long we
treated too early of course I went on
prophylactic treatment now you and I
we're in close contact as you were
beginning to come down with it and so
it's possible that I got it and I will
uh manifest symptoms it's also possible
I got away with it or it's possible
because I went on what we think is
prophylactic treatment that my symptoms
will be so mild I won't even notice it
but in any case I thought it would be
interesting in light of the fact that we
are broadcasting from outside solving a
problem which is how do we do our job
while you may have a still active and
contagious infection well okay this is
imperfect the lighting's not great it's
a little hot
um
there are airplane noises it's very nice
to see you it's great to sit next to the
last time we saw each other when we had
to curtail a short trip that you had
planned for us was on our 25th wedding
anniversary yep 25th wedding anniversary
and it was a delightful trip and I
really wish it hadn't been cut short but
um but anyway
that is the reason that um
that
there was nothing to be done so I was
exposed to it but anyway I I wanted to
read this I thought it would be
particularly I interrupted you before
you got to explain it is this you will
all recognize is our book Hunter
gatherer's Guide to the 21st century and
this book contains an afterward which I
am now going to read Because it's what
it's not how you treat books
it's not how you treat books okay well
um after the live stream we will have a
short tutorial on how no no we won't
okay all right
um so this is the afterward to
hunter-gatherers Guide to the 21st
century and I will do my attempt to read
it
in January of 2020 we went to the
tipatini biodiversity station in the
Ecuadorian Amazon to finish our first
draft of this book when we emerged from
our isolation as our phones came alive
for the first time in two weeks we were
confronted with a barrage of news mostly
trivial of which we had been blissfully
unaware but in that onslap Onslaught
there was one ominous report a case of a
novel coronavirus in Ecuador the
pathogen came from horseshoe bats had
jumped to people and then spread rapidly
first in Wuhan China and then beyond
as the two of us tried to make sense of
these first hints of a pandemic it
quickly became clear that there might be
more to the story Wuhan we soon learned
housed a bsl4 laboratory it was in fact
one of our planet's two main centers for
the research on bat-borne coronaviruses
these viruses were being studied in
Wuhan Wuhan and in North Carolina
because of fear among scientists that
such viruses could jump to people and
without very much evolutionary change
cause a dangerous pandemic if nothing
else the fact of the pandemic having
begun in one of two cities where these
viruses had been under intensive study
seemed a particular coincidence
as of the writing of this note in late
May 2021 the consensus in the scientific
establishment including National and
international regulators and the
mainstream press that follows them has
finally shifted to one of grudging
acceptance of the obvious that SARS cov2
May well have leaked from the Wuhan
Institute of virology
and the covid-19 pandemic might
therefore be for Humanity an entirely
self-inflicted wound
the strength of this hypothesis is
something we have been discussing on our
podcast Dark Horse since April of 2020.
those discussions caused a great deal of
derision and stigma to be directed at us
and it is bewildered it is a bewildering
relief to watch the world suddenly come
around to the plausibility of this
well-supported if unfortunate
explanation but no matter what Humanity
ultimately concludes about the
pandemic's origin there is a deeper
truth hovering just outside our
Collective awareness
covid-19 is a product of Technology no
matter what path it took to humans
consider this fact from the beginning of
the pandemic the virus showed
essentially zero capacity to transmit
outside put another way covid-19 is a
disease of buildings cars ships trains
and airplanes more than 99 percent of
the earth's surface is a coveted safe
Zone even in your own backyard the virus
will struggle mightily to infect anyone
it has no meaningful impact unless you
caught it before you walked out in the
park on the balcony at the beach we are
at least for now immune
the dependence of the virus on enclosed
spaces also means that had Humanity
agreed to avoid vectoring environments
for a few weeks the pandemic could have
been quickly brought to a halt but this
scenario in which we free ourselves and
lock down dangerous environments instead
is little more than an idle thought
experiment even though in evolutionary
terms these dangerous environments are
all brand new to humans the idea of
humanity staying outside them even for
just a few weeks is unthinkable
many individuals could do it but a
majority would be at a total loss even
though we evolved outside and despite
the fact that most of our ancestors
would have spent every hour of their
lives in what we now strangely call the
outdoors
we have forgotten the skills we once
knew so well
that knowledge of and comfort with our
natural environment has been replaced
with a different skill set one tuned to
pursuing value and avoiding harm in a
synthetic environment of our own device
our cognitive software has been
Rewritten and we have forgotten too much
to ever again be what we were the result
we are condemned to battle this pathogen
in bespoke environments in which we and
it have both grown to depend
that's the view from the ground that
Hume but the human dimension of this
pandemic is even clearer from 30 000
feet or more accurately at thirty
thousand feet
for it is excuse me I have now now
reading in the shade
for it is the way we have begun to
travel that really sets us up for the
pandemic disaster SARS cov2 crossed
oceans in hours and it didn't Pioneer
some ingenious new mode where once an
epidemic might have been held back by
barriers that limit human travel humans
now regularly transmit communicable
diseases from their continents of origin
to every corner of the globe
much as people thought little about
washing their hands prior to the germ
theory of disease we give no thought to
the scale of misery caused by a given
person transporting a new and nameless
cold virus to some continent that was
free of it the day before
novel coronavirus took advantage of that
nonchalance before the pathogen even had
a proper name
the covid-19 pandemic is a self is it is
itself a symptom of another disease
entirely the pages of this book we call
that disease hyper novelty it is caused
by a rate of technological change so
rapid that transitions in our
environment outstrip our capacity to
adapt you will not find the covid-19
pandemic specifically dissected here but
you will find a full exploration of the
hyper novelty crisis that left us
vulnerable to this virus a virus so weak
that it could have been cured with a bit
of well-coordinated fresh air
so I thought that revisit was worthwhile
in light of the fact that we are still
all dealing with the consequences of
this the people who have decided it's no
big deal that the world is overcovered
and they're just not going to think
about it they're not going to do
anything special and the people who
still treat it seriously as you and I do
and the people who still panic over it
and are wearing their masks outside as
they walk around we still see these
people occasionally
the answer is there's actually a
loophole
with this disease the fact that it
doesn't transmit outside was a loophole
and a properly run Planet a planet in
which experts weren't
just simply idiots who held a high
position would have told us here is how
you go about not disrupting your life
try to figure out how to do as much as
possible outside and we can retain as
much normalcy as uh as we can arrange
but they didn't tell us that
no they told us exactly the opposite yes
they told us go inside go home
go go home get the people you love sick
if you're sick
uh and uh don't come back and see us
until it's uh close to too late at which
point we'll uh we'll inflict our worst
harms on you yeah we'll put you on a
ventilator and give you a rem death
severe uh I don't know when that started
that was it was a little later but um
you know since replaced with um
Pax loaded but uh
um none of the solutions so-called uh
have been actually Solutions and that of
course as we have said over and over and
over again raises questions about about
why yeah so to what degree can we
imagine they were actually intended as
Solutions in the first place
um but here here we are in uh you know
in a summer where for a lot of people
it's been too hot it's been too smoky
it's been there have been too many fires
um to to go outside much and it that
being usually the season when people um
go out and uh re-up their vitamin D and
such
um still you should be trying and uh you
know everyone's in a in a different
different Locale but your particular
situation uh personal social emotional
uh should not be the one driving whether
or not you should be going outside if
there if there are reasons that you that
you can't be outside because because of
fires because of storms whatever that's
something different but
um really the um
the more time you spend outside the more
time you spend moving your body being
active getting every part of you moving
uh the healthier you're going to be
absolutely
all right
um I think I think we've covered the uh
the outside covered loophole and uh the
reason that we are broadcasting from
outside which is both nice and a little
hot I admits yeah
um yeah we're backlit-ish top lit
totally lit yeah yeah uh
which would you like to do would you
like me to meet to
um talk a little bit about
um stories and storytelling in tropical
forests sure or uh that's that's where
you want to go yep all right
so
let's see
I've been reading
a book as may not come as any surprise
to those who've been listening so far uh
it's it's this book uh It Is by Philip
Pullman called demon voices on stories
and storytelling Philip Pullman is the
author of the trilogy His Dark Materials
uh which I forgot to look up the names
of those three uh
books are shouldn't they be listed here
oh well
um anyway it's the um
it's the so-called fantasy although he
objects to that term uh Trilogy that
follows the
um the development and uh wisdom
enhancement as she grows of Lira a young
girl who uh
to and is in a world with demons uh
where you have a you have basically a
familiar as a child that changes form as
you're a child and then at some point
cements in place as a particular form
and so that explains the the title of
this book so anyway this is a book about
um about writing about story and it's a
series of essays that Pullman has given
places and
um quite quite compelling in many
regards and I wanted to share
a section from
an essay that he gave that he gave us a
talk called the path through the wood
and this was a talk that he gave in
uh I'm sure I can find it I'm not as
prepared as I might be
um
in
1999 at the fincon science fiction
convention at the University of turku in
August 1999. so he says
some of you might know that that Robert
Frost poem The Road Not Taken which I
think was used as the title of a book
not long ago
he talks Frost talks about coming to a
fork in the road through a wood having
to chose having to choose which way to
go and the poem ends
two roads diverged in a wood and I I
took the One Less Traveled by and that
has made all the difference
this incidentally was also kind of the
adopted tagline of the school where we
met
and um
and it's fantastic yes the adopted
tagline and the reason that the school
is named as it is yes indeed so again
two roads diverged in a wood and I I
took the One Less Traveled by and that
has made all the difference
so this is Pullman again here we have
two ideas the wood on the path the wood
or the forest if you like is a wild
space it's an unstructured space it's a
space full of possibilities it's a space
where anything can happen there are
monsters in the wood there are life
forms unlike any others there are quarks
and neutrinos and virtual particles it's
full of charm and strangeness it's
non-linear it just grew
the path on the other hand is a
structure and it has a function it leads
from here to there from A to B it's
extremely linear even when it doubles
back and Crosses itself it does so with
an air of purpose it says I know where
I'm going even if you don't
it was made
I expect you can see where this is going
each novel or story is a path because
it's linear because it begins on page
one and goes on subtly through all the
pages in the usual order until it gets
to the end that goes through a wood
the wood is the world in which the
characters live and have their being
it's the realm of all the things that
could possibly happen to them it's the
notional space where their histories
exist and where their future lives are
going to continue after the story
reaches the last page
parenthetical this is the point from
Pullman this is the point where
practitioners of literary Theory will
throw up their hands in disgust
characters don't have histories they
would say the only life they have is
that in the words on the page they are
not real people they are only literary
constructions to mistake the characters
in a novel for characters in real life
is to make a fundamental category error
it's naive to the point of stupidity etc
etc to these ladies and gentlemen of
theory I say thank you very much now go
away until you can tell me something
useful
end of parenthetical from Pullman
so the wood or the force is the sum of
all possibilities and he goes on and on
and on
and I'll stop there with the with the
reading for now
excuse me
um and so he talks for instance about
Cinderella and uh this the story of
Cinderella apparently exists in many uh
in many Traditions throughout the world
which tells us
um if those are truly independent
origins of that story that there is
something Universal there there is
something that truly speaks to uh to
humanity uh that and is not particular
to a particular time or place uh I think
that's true even if it isn't independent
Origins if it persists but it spreads to
multiple cultures oh if it's resonating
it's resonating it may not have been
um
critical enough to have been to have
originated there but yeah no um
convergence versus you know is is the
origin due to the common ancestor or to
or to convergence
um either way if it's persistent it
tells us something about uh the
importance to to humans to humanity but
there are things in the story of
Cinderella which we with which we are
all familiar uh that aren't in the story
in the path as it were but are clearly
in the wood that are clearly in the
universe that is Cinderella which is to
say for instance you know something
about how
um the house is heated in which she is
put to work effectively as a scholar
remain because she ends up with coal
dust all over her herself and therefore
you know that they don't have central
air not that they would coming from from
when the story originally does but uh to
this point Pullman says you know he
wrote he wrote a story from the
Cinderella wood from the world that is
brought to us uh through the path that
is the story that is Cinderella but
about one of the other characters in it
about one of the rats that was um
uh that was turned into a
I don't remember what one of the the
people opening the The Carriage that was
a pumpkin in an earlier life for
Cinderella and of course uh there is a
famous version of this in the form of
Hamlet and Rosencrantz and Guildenstern
Are Dead so Hamlet's too just
fairly insignificant characters
Rosencrantz and Guildenstern whom Tom
stoppard brilliant playwright pulls up
out of obscurity and uh and turns into
the lead characters in his play brothers
so he's borrowing from the Hamlet wood
as it were hit the world but the wood
and creating a different path through it
I think the stoppard example is
interesting because in some ways
stoppard
is he's sort of going beyond what
Pullman is saying because yes every
properly constructed World in which his
story takes place all of the other
features
ought to be explorable nothing ought to
not add up but what stoppard is in some
ways saying with Rosencrantz and
Guildenstern Are Dead is that I stoppard
can even do this with two characters who
are it's a rare case in Shakespeare's
situation where their pure plot device
yeah they're not real they weren't yeah
they were necessary to the story and so
they were just kind of invented up for
that purpose and stoppard takes them and
he's like well what if they did have
depth and a story and you know it's
obviously a marvelous piece of work but
uh but anyway it's
uh the fact that inevitably a story no
matter how short
suggests a world or a set of worlds in
which it would it would be necessary for
those worlds to exist in order for the
story to happen and that there's no
reason not to explore other trajectories
through those those habitats is is a
great idea exactly and this is you know
and here we get into questions of
cognitive dissonance versus
um reading something where your brain is
constantly throwing errors where the
story is inconsistent with its you know
the path that you're reading is
inconsistent with the wood in which it
exists and you've been told enough about
the wood uh that the path keeps breaking
its own rules right whereas being asked
uh to um to believe for instance in a
world in which there are humans like
Lira who have who have demons who have
Associates who have who who have
affiliate animals uh who are born with
them and change safe until they become
adults and then are fixed in terms of
their organismal form and they die with
them
it doesn't take that much to LEAP to
that we are never under any impression
that that is actually what is true and
this of course is is you know one of the
problems uh with
um modern understanding of um for
instance uh you know gender ideology
right
um that you can read something in what
is patently a an untrue situation and
get something out of it gets something
metaphorical out of it but it is a
mistake to LEAP to therefore that thing
is literally true therefore I a human
woman can change into being a human man
therefore I
um who adore my cat so much have him as
my demon and um you know could not live
if he went
um outside of a sphere of some number of
feet you know both of those things are
not true but they but they come from
Worlds that are compelling
and metaphorically instructive but
literally not true
so there's as you know something very
deep in your point about the connection
between something like
the new gender ideology slash nonsense
and violation of
proper if unstated rules of narrative
right and I would I would just put it
this way you and I have each made the
point that there is nothing wrong even
for those of us who are scientific
materialists there's nothing wrong with
the story that uh uses magical realism
as long as it is self-consistent as long
as it is not asking you to continue to
adjust your level of what you will
believe right right yes once there's so
this is a world in which there are
spells it is not that you just say the
words and they happen but you have to
learn to cast them for example this is a
world in which to get Between Worlds you
have a knife and you can cut holes into
different worlds and wow can that happen
no that cannot happen but in this world
it can use the subtle knife or you know
this is a
the spacecraft has a single violation of
physics in the sense that the outside
does not constrain the inside bigger on
the inside yeah
um so there's nothing wrong with these
things and even for us scientific
materialists they're fine the problem is
when you keep throwing new levels of
even Wilder exceptions then the point is
well no you already told me how magical
this realm is and now you're just being
you're being sloppy you're not even
sticking to the rule that you told me
you wanted me to accept so anyway that's
sloppy and not very interesting and it's
not the stuff of of great writing but
the problem is
when this happens when an author has
told you how magical the realm is and
then they up the ante by 50 and it's
like that's annoying
um they are violating the rule of the
universe they sold you yes when gender
activists
try to sell us on the idea that a man
who says he's a woman simply is a woman
and we say okay from the point of view
of how this person should be treated yes
up until the point where that becomes a
problem for the Universe I know I live
in and their point is nope that Universe
just changed
that this is a
transubstantiation that actually changes
what a person was such that uh Chelsea
Manning is the person who gave the
documents to Julian Assange wasn't
Bradley man he was Chelsea Manning
because she was Chelsea Manning the
whole time and the the fiction was
Bradley Manning no
you just told me I live in a universe I
don't live in and you're insisting that
I accept it and that that same annoyance
of
we can talk about how to treat each
other sure
we can do that as adults who recognize
that there are tensions between
competing uh claims on
rights
we cannot pretend that there is a truth
so sacred it was born five minutes ago
and it's so sacred that anything about
the actual universe that it violates now
has to change that is upside down
backwards and offensive and it is the
reason that we are now in the pickle
where people like you and me who
are interested in a world where
everybody is as free as possible to be
whoever they are best at being Bridal at
the very suggestion of these things
because of the the retconning of the
universe that we know we actually live
in the universe that you and I
professionally studied and understand
something about we're being told we have
to change what we know about the
universe in order to be kind to people
and the people who are telling us that
aren't being kind in the slightest well
I think it plays on some sort of nascent
latent in some cases explicit
good-hearted frankly libertarian
instincts that most people have
um in a sort of a
mid-20th century and later World in
which many of the Winds of of liberals
have been instantiated in in both in law
and in culture where
you can know for sure that as another
human being you share a certain number
of experiences and ways of understanding
the world but you cannot ever fully
understand what it is to be in someone
else's head but this is this is a large
part of what we do as humans we you know
we we engage in theory of mind and those
of us who don't try to are um
are dangerous frankly are dangerous and
at best deeply unpleasant to be around
anyone who is not actually trying to
figure out what the experience of other
human beings is is unpleasant at best
and dangerous often to be around
but one of the things that I think the
vast majority of us came to understand
you know for us this this was all
happening sort of before we were born as
we were growing up but is if someone
says to you actually that's not my
experience I had this experience uh it
is often valuable and interesting and
respectful to say oh
tell me about your experience then right
that doesn't mean that I don't get to
have an opinion about what it might be
like to be someone I'm not but it does
mean that I know that I have not had the
experience so that is true you will
never be a woman you will never be a
black man you will never be
um I don't even know what the correct
word is to use now a small person
a dwarf I guess this one is one version
of that right um and yet
um you have
um
engaged with both in reality and uh
through narrative uh stories as you know
as have I
um that include such people and we and
and read history and we have and we can
try
as much as possible to put ourselves in
the position of others
so then we have the weaponization of
this lived experience thing
into not only can't you know but you're
not allowed to
voice an opinion you're not allowed to
if you're an actor actress play that
kind of person you're not allowed to
borrow from the experience of which is
of course it's it's an anti-human
statement the idea that you're not
allowed to borrow right you're not
allowed to steal but the idea that
borrowing is inherently theft is is
juvenile and itself dangerous right so
we end up with this with this gender
ideology which frankly
um
some amount of it tricked me
and I remember I don't I did not expect
that we were going here today but
um I remember at some point when I was
teaching animal behavior back in like
the or the mid mid odds like gonna have
been 2008 or 2009. and I said something
about
um
sex and some students said don't you
mean gender I said it's the same thing
doesn't matter
and uh I have
kind of you know we you know we've said
a number of things about gender is sex
role and gender is a software of sex and
gender is the behavioral manifestation
of sex and all this and gender is more
fluid than sex and sexist binary and
gender is bimodal and I I still think
that that's useful because we do have
different
um there are other organisms that are
hermaphroditic either sequentially or
simultaneously and that do have once
they change sex a change in their sex
roles as well
but that's not us and that will never be
us that's not what humans are and so
there's this simultaneous like borrowing
off of the good and sort of
libertarian-ish instincts of people to
say oh is that your experience tell me
about it or I'm just I'm not going to
question it if that's your experience
you do you
and then there's the oh gosh I didn't
mean to offend uh okay I won't I won't
say anything about your experience and
and then we jump into this actually uh
them to us what you think is true about
reality is just a sign of your Phil in
theism here you know it's the patriarchy
it's the misogyny it's the turfism it's
like whatever it is and so we pretty
quickly Decay and to name calling which
is really the only recourse of those who
would deny reality uh and yet and yet
somehow in many circles they're they're
winning and so you know let let us
remember the the wood and and the path
of any particular story and when we read
fantasy for instance that does play
around with sex and gender uh like for
instance Octavia Butler does she's
fantastic her world's her Woods her
worlds are fantastic and she has I don't
remember which book it is but she has
one in which there's a third sex that is
that is necessary you know they're
humanoid they're they're like human it's
as if they're human but there's a third
sex that is necessary I think if I
remember correctly they're they're
humanoid
um and you read it and you learn
something about how the two sexes in
humans could be interacting that maybe
we aren't doing but you never forget
that this is a wood that this is a world
that is not ours
it's a different world it's a fictional
world
all right three points one of them is a
pushback I'll try to remember all three
yeah
um
one it strikes me that your exercise
I'm trying to remember what the name of
the Beatles that you the fraternity
fraternity of Beatles
um so Heather used to have an exercise
that she would give to take some exam
questions yeah one of the more advanced
exercises where she
switched up some biological facts and
then had the students figure out what
the world of the creatures in which
these facts had been altered in this
particular case yeah they had to figure
out um they were haploid diploid but the
Sexes were reversed so unlike actual I
may not Prince Hans bees and wasps sorry
I gotta go a little inside baseball here
um it was the males who were deploying
the females who were haploid and so I
asked them to First calculate all the
degrees of relatedness between close
family members as we can do for ants
bees and wasps and then predict the
social system based on those very
strange sets of relationships between
the
um
The fraternid Beetles you know named
with a wink to those who might need a
little help figuring out what the
relationships might be and this is not
this is a very difficult exercise
actually because you can't just simply
say that well we're just going to call
males females and females males because
the maleness and femaleness remains
intact and that has an unfudgable
characteristic so anyway great exercise
and it strikes me as consistent with the
idea of you know let's explore uh the
universe let's create the universe
implied uh by this important fact that
it has to be consistent with
all right second point is
I don't
we need to have doesn't have to be the
term gender but we need to have the idea
of the hardware of Sex and the software
of sex being different even in humans
and the reason that we do is because
cultures are so different this is this
is not an arbitrary fact
in humans
the a huge fraction more than in any
other creature a huge fraction of the
evolutionary information has been
offloaded by The genome into the
software layer
that creates some vulnerabilities and it
creates a massive opportunity for Rapid
Evolution that can therefore be highly
precise to particular environments or
particular circumstances this is the
magic of humans
and that magic of humans means that
sex roles do change they are not
completely flexible to another uh
excellent lesson that you were fond of
was the going into the anthropological
literature and looking at the patterns
that are violated where you know sex is
arbitrarily do certain jobs but a lot of
jobs are not arbitrarily distributed a
lot of jobs are not arbitrarily
distributed we're talking about things
like everything from like hunting marine
mammals to uh Gathering of vegetal foods
to basket weaving to you know karting of
of wool and making of rope and
um the interesting the interesting
finding there is that yes there are many
jobs especially because you've excluded
there the anatomically and physically
mandated things of gestation and
lactation there are a number of jobs
like hunting of brain mammals that in a
culture where it's done it's done by men
yep but there are also a number of jobs
and we talk about this in the sex and
gender chapter of hunter-gatherers guide
that are highly gendered but which
gender does it very strongly by culture
which tells you that it doesn't actually
matter this doesn't a manly work this
isn't womanly work it's just valuable
for there to be division of labor and
that you know that's that's a huge thing
that the whole gender ideology is
missing it's like you know what division
of labor has has been
um done terribly many many times but
there is value in division of labor and
it doesn't need to be done by sex but
that's an obvious way to split us
because we're about half and half and
all humans in throughout history who
have left descendants have been male or
female which raises some really
interesting questions and this is
another in addition to
a bunch of The evolutionary the Adaptive
uh
feature set of human beings being
offloaded to software which creates this
flexibility
it also creates it creates a potential
to to have an Adaptive culture set that
fits a particular environment but also
it allows a particular culture to change
over time and so we are in a position uh
it was for all cultures that war was the
province of men right
it is not inherently true that that
should remain the case if you are going
to be a fighter pilot there might be
certain things in which the strength
advantages a man has are necessary but
it is much less obvious that a woman
cannot be a fighter pilot in combat
they're excellent highly capable female
pilots who are going to be just as good
or better in combat now
that doesn't mean that it makes sense to
be in combat people will raise the
question about what happens if a woman
gets shot down she has vulnerabilities
that a man does not have Behind Enemy
Lines is that enough that we should
forbid this is there a value to a
division of labor that isn't about such
concrete issues you know you point out
that in places where what sex does a job
reverses when you move from one culture
to another it's still done by one sex
there are presumably adaptive reasons
for that right single single sex culture
um is different from from cultural
interactions with two Sexes right and
actually
so I think this is my personal belief I
think that the fact that women have so
thoroughly and effectively broken into
the highest levels of science is a great
Triumph of liberalism however there is a
question in it
men and women interact differently and
there's a question about
when women were excluded from that
environment unfair as that was to women
the culture of men where men by their
very nature push each other around is a
scientific modality or is at least one
of the components of a vibrant
scientific modality that the desire to
find what's wrong with what the other
person is saying is a core of how that
job is done well and the idea one will
find much more frequently that women
find an obligation to be supportive and
obligation to be supportive in a
scientific environment may be exactly
counterproductive and so no and I
actually I wrote about this in my um
uh the piece that was published I was
invited for I think it's the archives of
sexual behavior on the different kinds
of competition that men and women engage
in and the different modes I was taught
I decided to talk not just about not
about science so much but about business
uh and and finance and said you know
look it may be uh that a a female
approach can be effective here but if a
female approach is more likely to be
cryptic and
um not to direct and um as part of being
cryptic not public
uh it's going to take at best longer to
get things done and uh it's also likely
to lead to more conclu more confusion
and uh and make those people who are
looking for direct instruction direct
like did I do it right or did I not or
do you think that that was well done or
did you not leave them bewildered and
not sure how to go about things and you
know there are places where spending
time Meandering and thinking through all
the possibilities and not getting to the
point where we make a decision and get
something done is useful but we have to
recognize that these are different
styles which are broadly speaking
stereotypically sexed and uh and that in
a world where what you need to do is
make a decision and do it and then not
look back that is much more of a male
kind of of approach and something like
war or or any kind of combative
interaction as some business
interactions will be is much more suited
to a male typical style of Engagement
yes and in the case of the lab situation
there isn't I I I sure you'll agree uh
and I speak professionally here the
correct thing to do
that recovers the maximal gains
available is not to exclude women from
that environment but to expect the male
mode to be learned in the same way that
we expect uh that everybody in a
scientific environment should understand
the scientific method and therefore be
able to figure out when they are in
violation of it right when they're
projecting a hypothesis back on a data
set that they didn't have before they
collected that data we expect people not
to do that and so anyway the point is I
would want to know exactly what is meant
by the mail mode I'm less compelled that
in science precisely this is
um that male versus female
modes which we would have to Define very
precisely are inherently better I think
that um
not saying not being direct about a
critique of an idea is a problem and so
if that is what you are if that is what
you are putting under
um female mode here which um certainly
could belong there I would say yes
that's not that's not appropriate that
actually uh when when you think you have
something when you when you have
something to say or a critique of
something that has been said uh you know
be be respectful I was about to say be
kind but that word has been weaponized
right like be respectful but also be as
direct as you can be and that is it is
harder for women to do it it is like
it's not just about conditioning yeah
but this is what I'm saying is the
Instinct yeah but what what there
but
this is a reflection of a male mode that
functioned in a laboratory context that
is inherent to the scientific exercise
the instinct to falsify
for me to find flaws in what the person
who is speaking is saying and to point
them out publicly right that mode is
um
it is
fundamentally
scientific and it is natively
man and just as you would not I don't I
so I I object to that final piece of
this but I think we're well in the weeds
I don't think I don't think we're in the
weeds
a soldier
who is female in an environment where
the battle is technological and
therefore female is not a disadvantage
is expected to take on a combative
a Killer Instinct
rather than a peacemaking modality
peacemaking modality is
counterproductive on the battlefield
sure so my point is this is it doesn't
matter it doesn't combat no it's not
combat but it is
um
antagonistic
I don't think so and I I do think this
is just
um this is ultimately a semantic
discrepancy in which
um you know I would I would ask that you
go back and look carefully at what I
have described as the very as as as male
typical and female typical kinds of
competition and without having those
definitions on the table in front of us
we're just going to be going back no no
I remember I remember what she wrote and
um the
undermining
is not
scientifically helpful
it does not do the job of being
antagonistic it's not that there's not
an antagonistic mode in the female
typical but the you describe it as
cryptic and my point is that within a
lab group let's say right so
undermining is like combative right like
that's that's the that's the toxic
version of the two right so overt versus
covert right
um public versus versus cryptic if if we
are keeping the models
um male the male model of competition is
what I'm talking about
um and you're sort of extending it into
all interactions
um more more public more direct more
overt uh and female models being more
cryptic more covert
when in front of someone I think it in
order to determine whether or not what
they've got is actually As Good As It
Seems a more direct a more public
response is warranted however
there is a lot that is done uh through
thinking and through giving written
response for instance and so just as a
female typical model is more likely to
be comfortable with the written word uh
that having you know what what I used to
do for my students and what I used to do
in in grad school as well was go back
and forth a lot with in writing which I
became very skilled at I was very direct
but there is a time delay and it doesn't
require a face-to-face I think you're
wrong and here's why and I would do that
but I didn't always have it I didn't
know it necessarily and that doesn't
mean that I was hiding behind something
female or that that that femaleness was
was less good there is a different mode
that I think is potentially just as uh
just as appropriate and just as
effective but can manifest in a
different way
I agree and in the mentoring context
sure but I want to point out how this
has played out in recent history and I
think I think this will make it clear
the problem with the written critique
mode where critiques are leveled but
it's done in you know it's not done uh
overtly in the open it is overt but
there is a time delay well
let's look at what happened with uh
with covet Origins yep
a debate was had
we didn't know a debate was had debate
was had over email written critique
people did hold each other to account
uh power went out
power decided what the scenario was
going to be and the Very people who knew
exactly the things that made the
position unlikely fell into line before
it emerged into public and it was
presented as a consensus okay so you you
are responding to a grabbing and a
weaponization of what is a mode that can
be very effective and many men are
excellent at it but women may be
slightly more likely to be excellent at
it because of you know on average female
greater female capacity uh with words
compared to on average greater male
capacity with uh with numbers okay just
like lay that out there gets weaponized
as a way to obscure to hide to lie to uh
to pretend that things that we had the
discussion and we didn't have the
discussion that's that's entirely clear
and so you are arguing for an ability to
at the point that it seems like
something is being done out of view and
we are being told that it is done being
done in View and ability to like pull a
rip cord and say now is the time now is
the time that we need to go back into an
historical mode that is not time delayed
that is you know real time very direct
here we go let's talk and you're going
to respond to to my critiques as we sit
here together and I think I think you're
absolutely right I don't know I don't
know how to get something like that to
implement and obviously you've had you
know you've had any number of people say
oh you know Brett's wrong and you say
okay let's talk oh God no I well I can't
I I've got to go cut my hair or
something you know well and you know and
I'm much less likely to say okay let's
go
but I'm certain that the response would
be the same right but uh yes look
imagine that all of these things had
been done just simply in the open and it
is the difference between I'm just like
I'm just objecting to the in the open
part I know in this case there was a
bunch of stuff that was hidden but then
it pretended that it was in the open
well let's put it this so there is a way
to do critique with a time delay that is
still actually transparent I'm not
saying that that has been the case in
science for maybe ever okay okay I want
to make two points yeah we are in a
perilous situation yeah in a perilous
situation
meeting for coffee isn't meeting for
coffee
now we're talking about yet you will in
a second there are people that you might
only be willing to meet in a public
place
because it is protective of something
that is an actual danger right my point
is scientifically speaking that's where
we are I don't want any more
private discussions of anything because
we have seen that private is the space
in which somebody decided to paint you
and me as Kooks for saying things that
they privately believed right right yeah
I'm sorry wow well that is so that is so
far beyond the pale that I don't want
any more of that I want public
discussions because those public
discussions are the place you can't pull
that right so yeah that's that's a
that's an already broken down situation
but
um then then then they'd have lied
visibly right I mean they would now be
they would be all along in the position
that they are now in that we have seen
their emails but what were the chances
we were going to see their freaking
emails yeah so my feeling is you know
what if you're gonna play this game by
your own rules if you're gonna if you're
gonna do this as Mean Girls then we're
going to do this in public so that your
mean girl stuff comes back to haunt you
fair enough okay okay but I want to
point out that the idea of vigorous
um public often instantaneous critique
that I'm suggesting is more male in
nature it doesn't have to mean that we
are all out to embarrass each other
publicly and I want to point out that
shouldn't be the goal right it should
not be sometimes people need to be
embarrassed but in general it shouldn't
be the goal in a proper scientific
culture it is exactly the inverse and I
want to point out that inside of a
laboratory
right inside of a lab and Dick
Alexander's lab and Arnold cluge's lab
people held each other to account yes it
was not considered disrespectful it was
not understood to be mean and in fact
the real proper understanding of it is
it makes me stronger for you to throw
your best stuff at what I'm presenting
and see if what I'm presenting stands up
I will find out what's wrong with it if
you point it out if I go out into the
world wearing a bunch of gold stars and
I don't know how to think that makes me
look stupid but it also makes the lab I
came out to look stupid
it's bad for everybody we all get
smarter together if we hold each other
to account properly and we do it
respectfully and it's not mean and you
know it's mean to let people think that
they're doing great when they're not yes
that's what is mean the height of
respect is to deliver proper critique
yes because you're honing somebody
else's weapon
um so anyway that that's that's all I
wanted to to get on the table I feel
like I feel like we did a good job yeah
um I feel like that was two things that
you had three things to respond to but
uh yes
um
of course I know what the third one was
all right the third one was
this issue of lived experience that has
been weaponized there is a way there's
one context in which this
came up repeatedly before any of this
modern stuff and so we know something
about how it's properly navigated
it used to be
five six years ago
10 years ago that you and I would
encounter people who had a religious
perspective on how the stuff of the
universe came to its current state
in some ways if you look narrowly at
those claims they just simply violate
what you and I understand to have taken
place and so it could be a a an
intersection at which there's no
resolution
but
you and I have done very well
interacting with people who have such a
world view and when they present hey I
actually spoke to God I had an
interaction and I wasn't expecting to
but God spoke to me and I spoke back and
etc etc
you don't hear that as oh this person is
deranged you hear it is that was the
person's lived experience and I know
what universe that lived experience can
exist in that also is consistent with
the one that I've studied and thought
deeply about and it's one of
metaphorical truth it is one in which
the mind has mechanisms and they may be
read this way or the other because
adaptation has built us to to use
metaphor in order to solve problems that
we're not in a position to analytically
you know take the Bedrock whereas the
new atheist types jump to your Duran
right your deranged that is inconsistent
with the universe no it's not
yeah no the universe in which you exist
is one of adaptation in which a person
might very well have the experience of
having talked to God even though a
literal creature of that nature does not
exist right it does not mean that that
belief is not uh an important one so at
the point we've both made many many
times but look at how well the people
who have those beliefs are doing
compared to those of us who don't right
so all I wanted to get at was there is a
way to deal with lived experience that
does not pretend that it is nothing and
is not elevated to the status of
unimpeachable it is a fact of a universe
that certainly appears to be material in
nature that appears to abide by laws yes
there are things we cannot explain
perhaps there are things we will never
explain but there's no reason to think
so
if there is reason to think so it's not
a certain reason so all I'm saying is
like everything else this isn't as hard
as it's being made to be it's being made
artificially difficult
and it's being made artificially
Difficult by people who do not want us
to resolve these issues because they are
engaged in a cryptic exercise of power
yeah
um
well I thought this was going to be an
easy segue but we kind of went way far
away a reminder of the end of the Robert
Frost poem two roads diverged in wood
and I I took the One Less Traveled by
and that has made all the difference
when I read to you that section of from
the Pullman book which began with that
um
that bit from Robert Frost poem
one of your reactions was
it's like
if you want to say I'll say it it's like
the question of how do you teach
somebody to think about a tropical
forest uh
I preferred what I heard you say the
first time which is it's like being in a
tropical forest you know forget teaching
you know forget pretending that we
already have the stuff and um but it's
like it's like walking into tropical
forest
it's like walking in the sense and
discovering not the actual path that you
may or may not be on and may lose and
and all this but
starting to say oh oh there's there's
that and there's that and there's and I
don't
how do I make sense of this and as you
know as we say actually in the
um forward to the book
um
our very first not our very first trip
into the tropics but our second trip as
biologists when we were working there as
graduate students with John Vandermeer
one of our professors
um he walked into the into the
rainforest in Costa Rica and said you
know look at all the questions
and my response was I just see a lot of
green like I don't see any questions
here at all and they started showing up
they did they did
um but it took a while because it's so
much because the wood in that case is an
actual wood it's an actual rainforest
and it's so complex and it changes so
fast from like one foot to the next the
next foot and
um I'm talking about like measures of
distance rather than actual feed
um and I mean you can if you're trying
to teach it you can have a path in mind
of what it is you're trying to teach but
it's all it's all still the the wood and
it's so complex right well the reason
the reason I would make the point in the
way you like uh less okay is
a just be aware this conversation takes
place in the context that we do not know
very much about how tropical forests
work they are so complex that it is a
very difficult puzzle to sort them out
and so nobody here is pretending that we
understand them well enough and that we
are teaching the students to understand
them well also because that's not the
state of play but
the question of how you start you walk
into a forest and you could start by
thinking about it in terms of canopy
layers and what creatures live in each
of these canopy layers you could start
thinking about it trophically the energy
is captured by the plants in the form of
sunlight turned into sugars and starches
and and cellulose by photosynthesis
um
the heterotrophs eat the plants right
yeah there are a lot of ways you could
do it by the biomass of different uh
kinds of organisms you could do it by
phylogenetic systematics
none of them are correct
all of them are complete none of them
are the correct way
ah none of them are the correct way if
done properly they are all correct and
hopefully self-correcting and as we say
I think a couple times in our book
all true narratives must reconcile all
true scientific stories must reconcile
that's where we come full circle with
the with with Robert Frost here right
yeah so the point is actually you have
to get comfortable if you're dealing
with something like a tropical forest
you have to get comfortable with the
fact that you are picking a literal path
through it whether that path is
analytical or physical that path is not
it is a kind of the map is not the
territory the path is not the sum total
of the forest yeah but
anyone will do
actually
yes any any path
um will reveal something that is
consistent with any other path if the
path is true within that would right and
um the little bit of research that I
want to share here is actually
that I'm reminded with regard to the
wood and the path of being in Madagascar
the first time where we went
um where we went after we graduated from
college
and I was we were in ankarna in the far
north and it's it's a strange and
magical and
strange place and there's very little
surface water
mostly you have to go deep into these
caves and you can walk underground in
these these Caverns into these like
pockets of forest where the karst on the
Limestone carces collapse and you've got
these pockets of forests that are
connected to the outside world if you're
a bird you can fly in but if you're like
a lemur you're there for life or you
have to go through these caves and they
don't presumably but anyway I was
sitting there and in one of the few
places where surface water exists on in
Karana with a little stream watching
crowned lemurs which are beautiful
um
you know lemurs being these relatively
basal primates that are only in
Madagascar and I was watching them eat
the fruits of tamarind
and I thought I don't I don't think
Tamarind is from here and I had no way
to know that then but I you know once we
came back and this was between college
and uh we were going to be starting grad
school that fall in Michigan and I and I
looked into it and went yeah Tamarind
was interested in Indian fruit that was
introduced
um by humans to Madagascar who liked who
who were cultivating it and so my
because it's super delicious it is
delicious it's weird it's it's also like
on current it's a weird fruit it is um
and you know you have to have a taste
for it um but it's it's delicious uh and
it's it's very much kind of a mammal
fruit where you have like you it's it's
got this this thick husk and you have to
work on it with your thumbs so it's it's
probably you know very good for primates
in general and then you end up with
these big seeds that you have to kind of
suck on and chew on for a while to get
all the all the good fruit pulp off
um
but I thought huh I wonder if my
hypothesis became uh that primates and
places that coexist non-human primates
that coexist with humans will prefer the
fruits uh that are under cultivation or
were brought by humans and therefore the
native fruits uh will be getting slowly
less common in places where there's
fruit under cultivation that human
cultivation effectively even if it
doesn't directly compete against native
fruits will indirectly compete by
basically
um by having the same sensory
experiences and preferences
as some of the fruit dispersions in the
forest
so fast forward to our first summer in
grad school and I decided that I was
going to test the hypothesis in um in a
new world forest in a rainforest in
Costa Rica and this is exactly the same
Forest where John vanderveer spread his
arms wide look at all the questions and
all I saw was green and
and when it came time to spend the
several weeks doing the research that we
would then be presenting for our our
preliminary exams in the fall I couldn't
find any monkeys no monkeys at all there
were no monkeys and I still this day
don't know why there are no monkeys but
I was out in that Forest every day all
you know not all day but like certainly
every day from dawn to to noon and then
often again in the late afternoon
there's no point in going out um in the
hottest part of the day usually uh
unless you're doing a particular kind of
question but um never found the monkeys
but spent so much time that I stumbled
upon a natural experiment that was
happening in front of me and it was with
boys and frogs and I'm not going to go
into that whole story now but I you know
I pivoted because I couldn't exactly
test my hypothesis on
um primates preferring fruits that
humans have brought in if I couldn't
find the damn monkeys could I
um but the story that the path that I
pivoted to is totally consistent with
the hypothesis that is still so far as I
know not tested but is still active as a
possibility in in that forest and that
actually kind of brings us to This
research and I want to say something
about but you had something you wanted
to I want to say that we don't know if
the reason you couldn't find the monkeys
is because they were at the market
because they preferred humans that's
right they were buying up all the
mangoes yeah I don't think they were
buying them that doesn't sound like no
no they were not they were stuffing them
in their in their cheeks and other Orvis
all right that got weird fast the
monkeys I mean what do you expect all
right fair enough
um I mean they don't have suitcases do
they backpacks that's where my backpack
went yes yeah
um quite possible no okay sorry about
that
okay so
um there's this cool research uh that
came out in uh
uh the Journal of of uh Royal Society
um
uh proceedings B which is the biological
stuff it actually it came out a little
while ago but not too long ago called
seed dispersal syndrome predicts ethanol
concentration of fruits in a tropical
dry forest
and to just translate that um right off
the bat tropical dry forest here is
Guanacaste it's uh it's a Costa Rican
dry Force it's not a rainforest like we
were just talking about it's a seasonal
dry forest but where there is definite
seasonality of when things are fruiting
as there is anywhere but um it's it's
distinct there we spent a little bit of
time in Guanacaste ourselves and what
they mean here by sea dispersal syndrome
is they are characterizing mammals and
birds as the two major groups of classes
clades of organisms uh that tend to be
dispersing fruits
um which to say plants have an interest
in having their seeds dispersed and
fruit is a lure and a gift to those
animals who would disperse that fruit
and of course some animals cheat and
they eat the fruit and they leave the
seed where it is or they don't do what
is what is expected but in general
whereas pollinators are often smaller
bodied organisms often insects some bats
are pollinators some bats are dispersers
but here we're talking about
mostly larger bodied
mammals and birds and
um and they
I'll just I'll read this a little bit
from the introduction here
when that stops beeping perhaps this
never happens in Guanacaste or the
Amazon or Santa picky yeah no you may
not get covered but you will have to
endure the backup beep yes
groups of vertebrate seed dispersers
birds and mammals differ in their
typical activity patterns and the
sensory systems they rely on to find and
consume fruit
avian frugivores tend to be highly
visually oriented with tetrachromatic
color vision based on four cone types
and excellent visual Acuity they also
commonly swallow fruits whole
fruits with bird dispersal syndromes are
correspondingly characterized by did I
say birds fruits with bird dispersal
syndromes are correspondingly
characterized by small size absence of a
protective husk and high visual contrast
alternatively forgivorous mammals
including primates bats rodents and
ungulates are typically dichromatic to
Cone Vision Red Green colorblind
although monochromacy single cone Vision
colorblindness is found in some
nocturnal species and trichromacy three
cone Vision human normal color vision
characterizes some primates
additionally mammalian frugivores often
have sensitive hands and mouths complex
dentition and larger olfactory bulbs in
olfactory receptor Gene repertoires
reflecting these anatomical features
mammalian frugivores rely Less on vision
and moral faction and manual bucal
haptic sensation and processing during
fruit foraging indeed fruits with mammal
dispersal syndromes are typically duller
and less visually conspicuous but more
odoriferous
they say odiferous I always say
odoriferous yeah I'm gonna go with other
referencing that's not what they wrote
and can be covered by thick husk that
requires manual or bugle processing to
remove okay so that's a cool setup and
that's so they're basically going to go
in
um and say
um in advance of looking at in advance
of measuring any fruit for ethanol
concentration we are going to describe
um the fruits in terms of what they just
said and say is this is this going to
have like mammal dispersal syndrome or
avian dispersal syndrome or is it some
combination they will say there's you
know there's a bit of it's not perfect
because as they allude to here primates
have actually moved away from the
typical mammal mode and we are no longer
um lemur is less so but in the new world
here we're there are no lemurs it's all
simeons it's all um monkeys and us and
um and we've become once again more
visual all our olfactory lobe has become
our forebrain and and is the site of
processing of memory and and future
planning and we have frontation where
our eyes have moved to the front so we
have binocular vision and the sizes of
our noses have shrunk so we're more
bird-like in this way so you might
expect primate fruits to be to have a
have a have a like an intermediate
um kind of dispersal syndrome to bird
and mammal fruits because they might be
higher contrast and less odoriferous are
odiferous if you want
um so if I may have my screen back here
for a moment Zachary thank you surprised
you can hear him he's like way over
there
um
yeah I know he's listening to my mic he
says
um
so
they then they characterize these um
fruits as such and then they went out
into the field and they uh they measured
the ethanol content in a bunch of them
and they indeed found
um basically what you would ex what you
would expect so there's a there's some
good
um
yeah that's that's too complicated I'm
not going to show the phylogeny but I
will show this
um which is a range of percentage of
ethanol concentration that's percent
alcohol by volume of ripe fruits of
species sampled in Guanacaste by C
dispersal syndrome the birds are on the
left the the bird distributed fruits as
far as they've assessed are on the left
the mammal distributed Foods as far as
they've assessed are on the right and
what we see with these uh these uh box
plots at the bottom
um is uh how much ethanol each of them
have and with the exception of a couple
of the what they think are bird
distributed fruits there's not much
ethanol at all whereas a bunch of the
mammal distributed fruits have a lot of
alcohol in them including including
that's not a word including your
favorite and mine spondius momben oh
spondius is good and you know what and
so you can smell the alcohol when after
after it's dropped and you're just
walking across a field of spondius man
and that's really the only way you're
going to get spun to just because it's a
canopy tree yeah the fruits are 75 feet
up but it is a very tasty tasty fruit
but yeah it does uh quickly lean over
towards um you know it's getting a
little buzzed yeah I'm after five kind
of a fruit after five kind of a fruit
yeah so
um this is consistent with their
hypothesis and um and there's a there's
a lot that we could say here but I
really you know really just wanted to uh
point out here's a path that is kind of
related to that path that I thought I
saw those many years ago watching Crown
lemurs eat tamarind in Northern
Madagascar but a slightly different path
that is consistent with our
understanding of mammals frankly as
luscious and birds not so much and of
mammals appearing to prefer
um and it's you know there's there's no
way to know you know what was the first
thing but you've basically got a
positive feedback through selection uh
scenario here where if mammals
um going after fruit that tasted good to
them had a slight preference for alcohol
in their fruit then those fruits that
had a little bit of alcohol in them got
got their seeds dispersed more and on
and on and on and on so
did they have a pre-existing hypothesis
about which fruits were going to have
more ethanol and a rationale
uh it would just just that they thought
that the mammal the mammal distributed
fruits would have more ethanol because
they're they're treating the ethanol as
a reward distinct yes sugar yes exactly
and there's a number of reasons for that
and this gets into there's there's a lot
of chemistry here and it's still very
unclear uh I think I think we just we
science doesn't really know fully what's
going on here but
um
you get twice as many calories from the
sugar and alcohol as you do the sugar
and sugar
and while there is clearly a toxicity
associated with high alcohol there may
be a benefit at low alcohol levels so
you might indeed find that this is not a
binary like alcohol good or alcohol bad
but a little bit of alcohol like no
alcohol not as preferable for the for
the mammals who are Distributing fruits
a little bit of alcohol good a lot of
alcohol not so good and I think I may
have gone I wondered also about the
protecting
the reward if you're going to put a seed
if you're going to wrap a reward around
a seed
and that reward goes bad so that the
disperser won't eat it because they
might become sick or yes it doesn't
taste good is how they would perceive it
right that alcohol
might prevent the growth of certain
things that would tend to take over a
fruit and therefore become something
that uh if a mammal can process it
they would be willing you know and like
I say I've eaten plenty of spontious
fruits that were a little past their
Prime and they do have that alcoholic
kind of sense about them yes and it's
not
terribly off-putting it's not as good as
a perfectly exactly ripe spongius yeah
but it's not bad yeah no and I actually
I found myself
um foraging for blackberries yesterday I
went on a walk
since I wasn't allowed to go into human
company so um I went on a on a beautiful
walk and
um certainly tried a couple of
blackberries that weren't there yet and
had a couple that were perfect and a
couple that felt a little bit past their
Prime and just a little little a little
fermented
um he was just a couple
um more intriguing which is interesting
that's Bird fruit
um
blackberries yeah
I mean for one thing the growth habit of
the plant makes it very difficult for
anything that can't fly to get them do
you eat them yeah around the edges yeah
no deer at them all the time that's true
yeah I mean and then the blackberries
that are here introduced their MLA and
mostly so you know it's all there's all
sorts of layers of like what what was
the intention here but
um I'm not I I would put Blackberry at
at an intermediate uh you know it
doesn't have the husk it's not giant it
does have tiny seeds
um so
um so it does it does fit the avian
model to some degree but um they also do
have a delightful smell
when the sun is here that's true I
accept that this is a generalist yeah
actually
people don't talk enough about the
generalists
syndromes yeah usually syndromes isolate
you to a clade of dispersers or
Distributors well and I think I mean
with the Blackberry with any of those
that that clade of berries uh where it's
um
is it a true no I can't remember what
the what the category is but
um lots of tiny little seeds that are
inherently unextractable from the fruit
um you swallow that you swallow you are
going to be taking this like they don't
like these fruits are not interested in
toilets they have that's a that's a loss
for them but for everything else that's
eating them uh as as long as they don't
have a digestive tract that's you know a
centimeter long and it doesn't come out
right away they're going to be
dispersing the fruit somewhat so unless
there's something that the Blackberry is
benefiting from in the gut of birds or
the gut of mammals that is
um you know scratching it up and making
it more likely to
um to to germinate um I think they're
they're pretty generalist here's a
couple of other little little
um
fun things from this paper which which
just went tiny on me
no no this is from the discussion
notably the metabolic pathway used to
use to ferment sugars and produce
ethanol emerged in the early Cretaceous
at approximately the same time that
angiosperms shifted from producing small
wind dispersed fruits to large fleshy
vertebrate dispersed fruits with
fermentable sugars
so that's cool the timing is is
convergent
and then some forgivers mammals
including African elephants squirrel
monkeys pigtail macaques and aye eyes
are sensitive to ethanol odors as they
can smell them interesting eye eyes is
on that list and it shows up on this
final list some mammals including humans
African great apes and I eyes exhibit a
mutation in their adh7 Gene that yields
a 40-fold Improvement in enzymatic
efficiency for ethanol metabolism and
these animals may have significant
exposure to dietary ethanol humans
African great apes and eye eyes what are
eye eyes doing on the list IIs are this
crazy clade of lemurs that again are
only on Madagascar and insectivorous and
and well insectivorous but they also
they're eating gums they're like they're
they're using that long finger of theirs
to dig out stuff and and
um
so what what is happening there but it
does seem that we have a particular
ability to deal with alcohol and
therefore and and add to that although
they don't say it here I suspect that we
humans are also sensitive to ethanol
odors that we can we can process it
better
um enzymatic enzymatic efficiency or
ethanol metabolism and we can sense it
better and once you have those two
things you're probably going to seek it
out some if it has some value again at
low doses but not at High
yeah that's really cool yeah
okay that's my um
that's that's my path through tropical
forests for today all right yeah cool
you
were interested in uh I guess finishing
up
[Music]
um
Cartesian crisis is what you said
Artesian crisis is what I wanted to
point to and I will uh try to keep this
brief but I think it belongs on people's
radar I've alluded to it uh a number of
times but the cartesians obviously
reference to Renee Descartes and
the point is that Renee Descartes
arrives at his famous
um
kajuto Ergo soon
I think therefore I am as the solution
to a problem and I will claim that it's
not really a solution what it is is a
license to not solve the problem but
the problem is
Descartes realized that he could
establish personally almost none of the
things that he believed to be true
doesn't mean they were false but it
meant that they could be false and
because he didn't establish them himself
he had no way of knowing and that that's
a frightening condition to be in and
you couldn't laugh at this you can
imagine that he's worrying over nothing
because
how much do you really need to establish
you know in order to know that that's a
wall
I am assuming that photons are real that
they are bouncing off it in a way that
the lens in my eye can resolve them on
the retina and my brain can process the
images and I can establish none of these
things but you know what it's a wall so
yep that's that's why I think therefore
I am is good enough it's like look don't
worry so much you think they're do you
exist yeah how else would you be
thinking right it's not a proof but it
it's a it's a sufficient it's a
tautology that allows you to move on to
things that aren't liable to be more
productive but I think Descartes concern
about that which is not established by
you personally is actually
a very real feature of the landscape
that we exist in that the destruction of
all truth-seeking modes of every
institution in which truth might be
established on the basis of some rules
that we might agree on science is a good
way of establishing truth but you know
what science is being done in
universities and those universities are
corrupt at a level that is hard to
Fathom and so the things that they say
are true
might be but they're not likely to be
true because they're being said they're
in fact you can find universities are
now binding on to gender ideology and
claiming that men can become women and
they are tolerating mathematicians who
think that two plus two doesn't
necessarily equal four and they are
absolutely refusing to call out nonsense
when it emerges in fact presumably a
product of universities but in I think
it was Jama this week there was a new
paper
that claimed to scientifically evaluate
misinformation that was being
distributed online about covid when the
misinformation that they were talking
about turned out to be true so anyway
you've got a situation in which it's
worse than having nobody seeking the
truth you've got people who are the
official truth Seekers who are
systematically avoiding their job
they're they are they uh what's the
term for it they soft quit
they still are in the roles they're
still getting paid for it but they're
not seeking the damn truth quiet quit
um so okay that's the error we're living
in and what it means is
your newspaper isn't reporting the news
in fact I made the argument that
newspapers now report the news only when
it becomes sufficiently embarrassing for
them to avoid it like lab leak the truth
that lab leak was at least a likely
possibility was evident from early on
newspapers finally got around to
reporting it late when they couldn't not
report it and still look like a
newspaper so they were embarrassed into
it
likewise universities only teach lessons
that the students sign off on being
something that they will tolerate so
that's the that's the world we're living
in and it creates
a an artificial Darkness even those of
us who are absolutely interested in
figuring out what the truth is are
denied a data set that we can even go to
Independent of anybody the data set is
itself polluted and this problem I
believe you can see it with respect to
covet because we now have enough of
these cases where we have embarrassed
the authorities into grudgingly
acknowledging that there was you know
the FDA now says oh yes doctors do have
the right to prescribe Ivermectin
I always did really no you actually got
in the way of it you got you blocked it
at the pharmacy and you couldn't
convince the doctors that it didn't work
and then you blocked it at the pharmacy
you started confiscating it at the
border and so anyways working though
they're convincing people
sure but my point is okay you see it in
covet you can see the level of
that we are drenched in by the so-called
authorities and true Seekers
problem is those fools who did this to
our truth seeking mechanism have invited
an absolutely Unholy disaster that we
are now beginning
to see
and I want to point specifically to the
Lahaina fire in Maui and the hypotheses
of various conspiracies that are now
circulating
I don't know I have watched a certain
amount of this stuff and I find it very
very spooky
on the other hand the problem is when
what am I to think on the one hand do I
would I put it past certain members of
society to start a fire in which people
would be burned alive in order to make
Bank on a real estate land grab
no I know there are people who are that
demonic in fact I watched them during
covid deny people
treatment that would have saved them
that's that's why I called the Pierre
Corey episode the crime of the century
because we literally had a medicine that
was safe and effective and it was being
denied to patients who we were told it
was our obligation to protect that's
incredibly cynical and it resulted in a
huge amount of human suffering that was
totally avoidable
so I know there are people this bad
do I think they wouldn't do it over real
estate no do I think they wouldn't do it
in Hawaii no so do I think they couldn't
do it
in this case maybe I do think that but
I wouldn't put it past them and if I
wouldn't put it past them and maybe I
just haven't thought hard enough to
figure out how it would be accomplished
in this case maybe I'm missing it and
maybe I'll be persuaded next week that
it did happen but the point is
the right way to deal with the
complexities of a world like ours is to
have truth Seekers who are rewarded when
they're good at it
so that we get better and better at
figuring out what the truth is no matter
how bizarre it is no matter how
unpleasant it is and when you sabotage
truth seeking because you've got some
private opportunity that depends on
nobody being in a position to call you
out
you create
a dark hit this isn't an accidental
falling into a Dark Age this is an
artificial Dark Age in which nobody in
my opinion
assuming the conspiracy theories are
wrong I don't think all of them will be
but there's a question about you know
is the fire organic
I think so
um is the did these people whose
religion seems to be let no crisis go to
waste did they immediately recognize
that there was an opportunity and jump
on it
uh and so that's why all sorts of things
seem conspiracatorial I don't know but
here's my point
we don't have truth seeking
because it was sabotaged it was
sabotaged by people with narrow
interests in
selling or making political gains
that they wouldn't have been able to
make if we were able to figure out what
was going on so the reasons that true
seeking with sabotage are not hard to
find the degree to which it's been
sabotaged is pretty shocking but if you
paid attention during covid it's
undeniable the truth the truth was
absolutely hidden and the only reason
that we now have a decent grasp on a
bunch of it is that a small number of
people refuse to go along with it they
were top-notch in many cases and they
were able to bring these through a
mechanism like podcasting that was
sufficiently unregulated that even the
attempts to shut down these discussions
didn't work that's not the way tree
seeking is supposed to be done but if we
have to do it that way so be it
yeah I mean I think
fascinating that
um
the focus on missed this and Mal
information
by which we and many others have been
censored sometimes silenced shut down
demonetized all of this
shows up at a moment of this quickening
this quickening in terms of uh the the
breakdown of Cartesian reality
right uh because it is exactly at this
at this moment uh that uh those who are
still believing what they are told what
comes out of the the box from their
favorite anchors on the networks that
have existed for for many many decades
and how could they possibly be wrong now
um the people who believe that the plane
is so loud it's so very loud
yeah
I'm gonna start talking again now yeah
they flew off yeah
um
those people are being fed
stories about how anyone who doesn't
believe the talking heads on the
networks that have existed forever are
engaging in
lies misinformation disinformation
malinformation and it's it's perfectly
timed and there are a lot of things that
are perfectly timed these days and maybe
it's just because everything is
happening at once
but it is
Beyond alarming
disconcerting to say the least Beyond
alarming
uh to watch natural disasters
and have one of the first thoughts be
what is actually happening
what is actually happening and how could
I find out
so
we have to figure out how to
progress in an era where we cannot
possibly establish things that our
well-being depends on
utterly
obviously folks in Maui have a serious
question on their hands about whether or
not there is something afoot
not something a foot could be
um
of many different levels it could be
people taking advantage of a crisis it
could be incompetence at an amazing
level it could be a conspiracy from the
get-go and the idea that anybody people
will mock them of course for leaping to
conspiracy theories but the problem is
whose fault is that
it's the fault of the people who
destroyed proper truth seeking right
it's the fault of the people who destroy
journalism
and the
the
problem is that in a world you know
whose fault is it that uh
I don't want to use the term anti-vaxx
because it's obviously a weapon of in
and of itself much like the term
conspiracy theory but whose fault is it
that so many people are now wildly
skeptical of vaccines that they weren't
skeptical of
three years ago
well it's it's the vaccine manufacturers
that's whose fault it is and even if the
vaccines that people are now skeptical
of are what they claim to be you can't
fault people for wondering when you've
lied to them about something else you
call the vaccine so
we have had somebody cultivate a Blinder
that they have put on
society and it is resulting in every
kind of Madness and I want to connect
one last piece of madness here
in
tweeting about this live stream that you
were going to do today
I said something about us
um
broadcasting from outside our comfort
zone and I was really just joking about
being outside
but some which is exactly our comfort
zone but not where we usually podcast
from right right
um
but in any case some folks showed up and
speculated about whether or not outside
our comfort zone meant that I was going
to address the JQ
what's that oh I believe that's the
Jewish question
you remember like whether we Jews are to
be tolerated
now seriously yeah
so here's here's my point I don't really
want to go after these individuals
but
there is no Jewish question
there is a question called lineage
there are patterns of History
seeking the truth of these patterns and
understanding what their implication is
for the present is what we are supposed
to be doing
treating this as some lineage which is
suspect in some people's minds in a
completely predictable way right this is
a feature of History there's a reason
that people go after Jews when history
takes a certain turn we will come back
to this in the future but my point is
that that Cartesian crisis that was
created presumably by cynical powerful
people who enlarged their slice of the
pie at the expense of the total size of
the pie who externalized harm onto
others in order to make a profit those
people are now exposing us to all manner
of dangers true seeking is what allowed
us to navigate and they are now exposing
us to everything from the inability to
navigate a Public Health crisis because
our Public Health authorities are
obviously on the take and unreliable to
a Revival of
anti-Semitism and we all know where this
goes right what is the Jewish question
right that is that is now being
discussed as if we're all supposed to be
pondering it as if it's a real question
so anyway
it's dangerous times it's dangerous
times and the final final thing I will
say is on the narrow question of what
took place in Maui what things look like
on the ground I am going to do a live
podcast later today I think people will
want to tune in
um we have a a
special guest that I think is in an
excellent position to help us dress this
question and we can do our own private
truth seeking because the uh the
official true Seekers are they've gone
fishing oh great uh when when is that
going to be I believe it is three
o'clock Pacific
but that could change okay we are
currently believe it is 3 30 Pacific
time today live stream today on all the
usual channels or on locals or what are
you gonna be
Rumble and
Rumble and YouTube uh normal live stream
cool all right great it was a surprise
to me well it's awesome Outdoors are
very is a very surprising place
I've noticed full of blackberries yes
um
all right well
um somehow we haven't melted although
we've made that our pants are stuck
toward
Bears here it got hot yes it is although
it's not a hot compared to how it is
elsewhere yeah no no it's actually yeah
man Summer's here so nice
um Maddie can tell we're about to be
done she's like it's time to throw the
frisbee isn't it Maddie yes he does not
throw it very well no no she doesn't but
she Chomps on it well all right um so
that's gonna happen I was gonna say lots
of good guest episodes coming out now
which is true but um uh live stream
coming up later today uh another one uh
check out check out always check out
Natural Selections uh this week uh
because we were going away for our
anniversary I just linked to some some
stuff that had drawn my attention this
week
um about
um
medical researchers being shocked that
the thymus might turn out to be useful
after all whoa I know
um an excellent David Samuels piece on
Barack Obama an interview with Obama's
biographer and a little thing from 1950s
women's Magazine on how to find a
husband
it's been all sorts of useful useful
advice totally I know you're not in the
market neither am I but for those of you
who are yeah who are in the market for a
husband yeah yeah you might check that
out
um okay so again are we we're moving
lots of stuff to locals please join
please join us there
um if you're if you're watching now
right now you may be in the chat on
locals uh we're going to be releasing
whenever there's a
um I guess a recorded guest episode uh
it's gonna go on locals first for 24
hours on Saturday and then it'll be on a
release the public a day later on
Sundays and we're doing our private q a
on locals so if you've been on my
patreon go there check out
um
check out a way to get into locals
um uh and uh if you're not on my patreon
already you subscribe on Rumble go to
locals there's lots of ways in and we
encourage you to do that all right
couple more things yeah
check out the
Umberto maduri and Paul Merrick episode
of the podcast people have had a really
profound reaction to it in many cases
it's a groundbreaking story broken right
here on Dark Horse well worth a look
also check out the web 3 podcast so both
of those are recently out
um
wasn't done talking about locals yet oh
we just go there yes you also get access
to the Discord server on locals not
quite yet but it's going to happen
before the end of the month so lots of
good stuff on locals I have more but no
no I'm I'm where I needed to go okay
okay
um
we've got great stuff at
darkhorsestore.org
where you can find things like psyop
until proven otherwise
so much is now
yes I happen to approve it otherwise we
also have epic Tabby and at some point
maybe we should we should do people wolf
it's time for people wolf yeah we should
get people wolf up there uh Pfizer the
breakthroughs never stop all that stuff
available at the store at
darkhorsestore.org you can find that
book which is buried underneath the
laboratory laboratory Network yep oh wow
available everywhere books are sold
including
um New York Times bestseller Times
bestseller despite their attempts to
claim oh we don't have any copies at all
or Plum out the publisher nope nope uh
still still made to the New York Times
bestseller list
um we still do have our patreons open
we're trying to shunt people into into
locals but um you're having great
conversations at yours as well
um
this card I already mentioned okay so
our sponsors this week were MD hearing
seed and soul I believe all awesome
um consider going there there'll be
links in the show notes and remember
that we are supported by you our
audience
um
so join us on Rumble subscribe on Rumble
join us at locals uh consider coming
over and joining me at Natural
Selections lots of good things to to be
found in all those places and share
share what you find uh with people who
you think it might educate entertain
irritate but not so much that uh they
have to try to destroy your social
standing by because you shared such a
thing
um or you know you you decide for
yourself what what the what threshold is
and until we see you next time
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside stay outside yeah
free one
foreign
[Music]